[Música]
bienvenidos a medio ambiente de france
24 soy maría clara calle por marina
colorado esta semana es clave para las
acciones climáticas por un lado el
presidente de eeuu joe biden
invitó a más de 40 líderes a una cumbre
virtual para impulsar compromisos más
ambiciosos de cara al cap 26 la
conferencia de la onu sobre el cambio
climático que se realizará en noviembre
en glasgow antes de la reunión de la
casablanca decenas de gobiernos
subnacionales se reunieron en el
iberoamérica
erdei zammit para plantear sus
compromisos y buscar alianzas con eeuu
el propósito en común es combatir el
calentamiento global y este 2020 fue uno
de los tres años más calientes en el
récord mundial la temperatura media del
año pasado fue 12 grados centígrados por
encima de los niveles preindustriales
cuando el acuerdo de parís busca que no
supere los 15 grados si eso ocurre las
consecuencias serían catastróficas con
un aumento acelerado del nivel del mar y
con un clima errático entre fuertes
sequías
acciones sin precedentes
por eso hay un llamado para que las
acciones contra el cambio climático sean
más ambiciosas en ese contexto el
presidente baiden aprovechó el día de la
tierra el 22 de abril para citar a los
líderes de los países que representan el
87 por ciento de la contaminación
mundial eeuu no sólo les pide que
contribuyan más con la reducción de las
emisiones de carbono sino que además
traza su nueva meta en el marco del
acuerdo de parís conversé con isabel
cavelier la cofundadora de transforma
una organización colombiana que
contribuye a crear un modelo de
desarrollo sostenible ella también fue
negociadora de cambio climático ante la
onu cavelier explica qué significa
la cumbre de eeuu y como el nuevo papel
del país impactará en américa latina'
sin duda marca un cambio de liderazgo
importante porque significa que eeuu y
su nueva administración ha tomado la
fuerza política para convocar a otros
líderes pero la verdadera prueba la
veremos cuando sepamos qué es lo que
eeuu se va a comprometer a hacer en la
práctica cuál va a ser su nuevo
compromiso ante el acuerdo de parís
debería ser al menos la reducción de un
50 por ciento de sus emisiones a 2030
sino más eso realmente de notaría que
están tomando el liderazgo una cumbre es
importante pero no es suficiente para
mostrar que el liderazgo ha vuelto a la
casablanca américa latina va a haber una
aceleración y un aumento de la
relevancia del tema del cambio climático
en todas sus relaciones diplomáticas con
uno de sus principales socios regionales
que es eeuu y con un énfasis sin duda en
la aceleración de la transición
energética y de la lucha contra la
deforestación muchos de los gobiernos de
américa latina están muy por detrás de
lo que es necesario para
a resolver la crisis climática otros
tienen buenos compromisos pero todavía
no sabemos qué va a pasar con la
implementación esperemos que esta nueva
administración en eeuu cambie ese
panorama en el buen sentido que
contribuye a que la implementación se
acelere en aquellos países donde hay
buenos compromisos pero no tanta
implementación como es el caso de
colombia y que realmente cambien las
políticas en el buen sentido en países
que están muy ligados como lo son por
ejemplo brasil o méxico veremos mucha
más presión de nuestro vecino del norte
y sin duda de otros países que también
se van a juntar en esta lucha contra el
cambio climático que es tan urgente
desde américa latina hay una apuesta
local por parte de algunos mandatarios
como lo explica sebastián navarro el
enviado global de la ruta santiago
blasco esta es una alianza que busca que
los gobiernos locales líder en la acción
climática ya que las ciudades emiten el
70 por ciento de los gases de efecto
invernadero del planeta
bueno hasta ahora maría clara los países
las naciones dictaban las el ritmo de
las negociaciones yo creo que ahora esto
va a ser al revés creo que las ciudades
serán realmente quien terminen
marcándole el ritmo a los países es muy
ambicioso lo que estoy diciendo pero en
la realidad son quienes tienen la
capacidad de ejecutar en territorio
y realmente poder cumplir
con las metas estipuladas ya que después
de 25 años quedó comprobado que las
naciones no solo no cumplieron con las
metas de reducción de emisiones sino que
las aumentaron
por eso es que los líderes locales se
reunieron en iberoamérica del samyd el
21 de abril allí ratificaron su
ambiciosa apuesta de lograr que en 2040
haya un equilibrio de las emisiones de
carbono también le plantean a la casa
blanca cuáles son las metas de los
gobiernos subnacionales y le piden un
respaldo financiero las ciudades estamos
anunciando los compromisos multinivel
desde américa latina para que la
administración by denny la oficina de
kerry sepan cuál es el verdadero
compromiso de la región el secretario
que ree fue muy claro en decir que eeuu
volvía al acuerdo de parís e iba a
tratar de compensar estos cuatro años en
los que el expresidente trump estuvo
afuera de las negociaciones
internacionales
creemos que es fundamental un plan de
financiamiento masivo un nuevo plan
marshall verde que tal vez podría
empezar en centroamérica y en otras
regiones de américa latina'
veremos que hay una oportunidad
histórica de que la tecnología del
liderazgo de california por ejemplo en
eeuu termine siendo el eje rector de las
políticas públicas de eeuu y en ese
sentido américa latina tiene una
posición estratégica que puede acompañar
y también debe recibir financiamiento
para que eso pase con estas palabras de
sebastián navarro me despido recuerden
que pueden ampliar esta información en
france24 y volver a ver todos nuestros
programas de medio ambiente en france24
punto com
[Música]